looking at the farm kids here today it's
hard to imagine what it looked like 20
years ago razed to the ground by allied
bombs in the Second World War the East
German government left the ruins in
place as a reminder of the horrors of
war that legacy is still visible in the
darkest stone bricks from the original
Church the first time I came here it was
after the fall of the Berlin Wall on an
icy cold February morning in 1990 when I
came back in 2004 I saw the following
curves re-erected and there were tears
in my eyes remember from the old days
when they called it the black ruin and
now the frauenkirche has been rebuilt
and we loved it especially as I was born
in Dresden first completed in 1743 the
pollen keisha or Church of Our Lady was
restored according to the original plans
of Baroque era architect Georg a bear
today it draws thousands of visitors
every day they come for the church
services or concerts all just to take a
look inside
restoring the church to its former
Majesty was no small undertaking an
unprecedented worldwide appeal for funds
raised more than 110 million euros
covering over half the eventual costs
for reconstruction the local media
talked of the miracle of Dresden
among the major proponents was Ludwig
Kirkland a world-famous virtuosa on the
baroque trumpet and conductor goodlow
headed a foundation and held classical
concerts for the cause his fundraising
heroics and him official honours from
the German President and Britain's Queen
Elizabeth
Jesus combined a few verses here but I
am grateful to be part of that sense of
community it wasn't so much about saying
thank you for getting something it was
more about people feeling it was a gift
just being able to be involved Ava had
Burgin led the project a labor of love
like no other in his life it allows the
frauenkirche share was returned to the
dresden skyline and the kind of letter
view has been completely restored
it was then clear to everyone at the
frontier she is the symbol of Dresden
plus it was essentially the building
that sped up the reconstruction of
Dresden in general thought in 1748
bernardo vallata
called Canaletto painted his legendary
view across the river Elbe in an era
when Dresden was dubbed the Florence of
the north the church was part of the
famous skyline until that fateful night
of February 13th 1945 after collapsing
during the firestone caused by allied
carpet bombing the church was history it
seemed
but four years after post Cold War
German reunification in 1994 the
foundation stone for its revival was
laid the reconstruction incorporated
more than eight thousand four hundred
sandstone bricks
salvaged from the ruins donations
received from across the world helped
ensure the church was completed on
schedule some 60 thousand people
gathered in June 2004 to witness the
finishing touch the installation of the
cupola and gold cross it was
reconsecrated
on October 30th 2005 forever had Berger
and his team it was a triumph over
conditions and critics
I still get locals or visitors today
saying that originally they were against
it after seeing the foundation and
everything else that emerged around it
they appreciate its importance for the
city and its people and they have to say
it was the right thing to do the iconic
landmark has been restored to its former
glory and height of 67 meters it's
visible on the horizon from kilometers
around
a viewing platform gives visitors
stunning panoramic views of a city
reborn from the ashes